one of the most popular questions that i
always get is what countries should do
about bitcoin well there's a couple of
things that i think they can actionably
do but it all rolls up under one idea
plug your country into the bitcoin
network what do i mean what's pretty
simple what i basically would do is the
following the first thing is that i
would buy bitcoin and i would put it on
my central bank balance sheet it's a
finite asset that continues to get more
and more adoption and therefore the u.s
dollar value continues to go up over
time it's a great asset to have as a
reserve on that balance sheet the second
thing that i would do is i would allow
everyone within my country to go ahead
and use bitcoin what that means is that
they can buy and sell it at free will
they can also hold it they're allowed to
pay for it for certain items goods and
services they also can pay their taxes
or some sort of fees to the government
in bitcoin and if you happen to work for
the government you also can get paid in
bitcoin as well so now all of a sudden
not only would i be holding bitcoin on
my central bank balance sheet as a store
value but i would allow my citizens and
my government workers to actually use it
as a medium of exchange
on top of that i would scour my country
and i would find various places where i
have energy production occurring i would
then go ahead and build bitcoin mining
facilities so i can start to participate
not only economic upside of securing the
bitcoin network but also it would be a
great education point for my citizens
and those that are interested in what my
country is doing on top of that i likely
would then start to think about what
else could i do to plug my country into
the bitcoin network you could do things
like issue bitcoin backed bonds where
you actually issue some sort of
municipal or federal debt you then take
a portion of the proceeds and you go
ahead and you either build out more
mining facilities or buy bitcoin to
allow for that economic upside to
actually change the return profile of
the bond and then lastly one of the most
important things that i think that
people should think about if they are
running a country is i would run a
national education campaign i would
explain to them listen we as a country
we are not necessarily the most
developed nation in the world but we
want to become one of the leaders in
this new technology era and the best way
for us to do that is to embrace digital
sound money and what i need you all to
do is understand how the technology
works i need you if you're an
entrepreneur to build around this
technology to build all sorts of
applications interfaces and
infrastructure if you're an investor i
need you to go ahead and fund all that
building that's happening i need you to
help fund the infrastructure around
mining and you should help fund all
sorts of new improvements to the user
experience and then lastly and probably
most importantly is i would have to take
a hard look internally should i actually
conduct a speculative attack should i
create more of my own currency that soft
fiat currency and use it to convert into
hard digital sound money the first
country that ultimately decides to do
this is likely to have a significant
advantage moving forward we've seen some
countries like el salvador do pieces of
this plan but we still have yet to see a
country that says we explicitly are
going to create our fiat currency with
the hopes and intentions of buying
bitcoin i do think that it will happen
in the next couple of decades the
question is just when and who will be
the first but once somebody breaches
that strategy and they begin to conduct
that speculative attack i think that you
will see many many countries follow suit
so ultimately i think that this
decentralized digital transparent system
known as bitcoin will continue to become
pervasive throughout the global economy
more and more people institutions
organizations corporations and
ultimately nation-states will adopt it
the question is just at what point will
the nation-states get comfortable at
what point will they actually go ahead
and start to execute on this plan some
of them will do it because they're
trying to actually prevent the
innovator's dilemma will try to disrupt
themselves from being a developed nation
and still stay at the forefront and
others will do it at a pure necessity
they'll realize that their future is
dire and the first countries that start
to do this will benefit and therefore
out of pure necessity they'll go ahead
and they'll adopt bitcoin this is going
to be a wild number of decades and i'm
excited to see how it all plays out